[Inaudible].
Um, I don't know how to use this thing, dude. Ah,
crap. But yeah. Uh, thank you DGI for this amazing gift. Uh,
this is a Maverick air. I have no idea how to fly it, but uh it's okay.
I got Matthew here. So Matthew, come here. Why don't you teach.
Me how to fly this? Oh, no, no. Okay. All right.
Let's just shut the camera. Shut the camera.
My 24th year was a year of growth and it all started our
March 12th, 2017.
I spent my 24th birthday sleeping on the train in Korea after clubbing.
I then moved to New York and started my first full-time job at Buzzfeed as a
data scientist.
I made my first appearance in a Buzzfeed video that 15 minutes of fame felt
pretty good. And I appeared in more Buzzfeed videos.
I then moved to bay area and started my job at Facebook as a data scientist,
working for the video creator team. I dressed up as my Bitmoji for Halloween,
and then I met my UCO and did a call with her.
And then finally I started the startup series and I forced all my coworkers to
be in them. And here I am today,
blessed with an amazing team at work. But most importantly,
I'm blessed a few guys who supported me along the way and thank you for making
this community amazing, but it wasn't always that easy.
It wasn't all smooth sailing actually face a lot of failures before realizing
that what I really needed was to learn, to accept myself with what I have.
I tried starting a startup and felt six times during college.
I applied to product management positions at Facebook and Google with no offers.
I worked for a whole year making videos on YouTube and Facebook only to gain
200 subscribers at the end.
But I continued to pursue those goals because setbacks are hard,
but they're the ones that will teach you the most about yourself,
what you're capable of and what you really want.
And don't forget that the things are work achieving will never be easy to say
yes to the grind,
because I know that one day somewhere or someone recognize
your effort and you'll be rewarded. But remember,
before everything else before you do sight of what's important,
you have to step back and remember who were there for you and who made trickles
possible.
[inaudible].
The, thank you for all you guys who came along the way,
but I'm just getting started.
My goal this year is to cherish everything you guys have given to me.
And I will give it back to you guys, however I can,
because I owe it to you guys. So thank you so much and I'll see you soon.
Okay.